unterwegs mit der niederländischen
Polizei im Kampf gegen die
Drogenmafia ich denke dass es ein guter
Fang ist was nur wenig bekannt ist für
die Produktion synthetischer Drogen
braucht es nicht nur viel Chemie es
entstehen Tonnen ätzenden Mülls der
landet dann meist einfach in der
Natur hier wohnen überall Leute hier
spielen Kinder getrieben von Profitgier
setzen die Kartelle die Bevölkerung
massiv unter Druck
wir haben einen Brief in den Briefkasten
geworfen und in dem wurde gedroht wir
wissen wo deine Kinder zur Schule
gehen wie gefährlich ist der Giftmüll
für Mensch und
[Musik]
Natur
eine verschlafene Siedlung am Rande von
preußischoldendorf knapp 50 km nördlich
von
Bielefeld im April 2019 ist es vorbei
mit der Ruhe wir konnten es einfach gar
nicht vorstellen dass bei uns hier in
dieser ja dörflichen Umgebung das dann
so ein großes Drogenlabor hier aufgebaut
werden kann ohne dass es irgendeiner
mitbekommt der Leiter der Freiwilligen
Feuerwehr Ralf Lori wird an diesem
sonntagmgen beim Frühstück
aufgeschreckt beim Blick aus dem Fenster
entdeckt er einen Brand unweit seines
Wohnhauses genau da wo er seine
Werkstatt
hat Lori fährt schnell zum
Einsatzort als er ankommt verlassen zwei
Unbekannte die brennende Halle die einem
lokalen Unternehmer
gehört in dem augenbl kamen dann auch
schon zwei ja Herren aus dem Gebäude
raus der ein hatte auch eine filtermaske
auf halsüber Kopf flüchten sie im
Lieferwagen auch die Kollegen erreichen
nun den Unglücksort und dringen zur
ersten Erkundung in die Halle ein noch
verstehen sie nicht was sie
sehen unzählige Propangasflaschen
gestapelt im Eingangsbereich kaum ein
Durchkommen die explosiven Flaschen sind
nicht nur gefährlich sondern auch
ziemlich untypisch braucht jemand so
viel
Gas die Masse hat uns so ein bisschen
stutzig gemacht in der Halle 1000 l
Kanister gefüllt mit Chemikalien
womöglich nicht nur toxisch sondern auch
noch
explosiv diese ganze Situation war für
alle so ein bisschen nicht überfordernd
aber schon
undurchsichtig im Laufe der nächsten
Stunden wird sich herausstellen Lori und
sein Team haben es mit keinem normalen
Brand zu tun
sie haben das größte jemals in
Deutschland entdeckte Drogenlabor
betreten dezember 2022 Limburg in den
Niederlanden wir sind mit einem
verdeckten Ermittler der
niederländischen Polizei
unterwegs um ihn zu schützen haben wir
ihn unkenntlich gemacht und nennen ihn
Jan
beukels
also ist immer schön also es ist immer
schön es ist immer spannend so mitten in
der Nacht wir haben Information dass
vielleicht irgendwo in Bering das ist
ein Dorf hier in der Nähe ein
Drogenlabor ist wir wissen nicht ob da
Leute sind jetzt das
Sondereinsatzkommando geht zuerst rein
und die gucken dann die machen die Sache
sicher wenn da Leute sind werden die
verhaftet und wenn da Waffen sind werden
die beschlagnahmt einchlagn von
Waffen hinter wem muss ich her fahren
fahre hinter jo
her wem dem mit dem
Toyota die gängigsten synthetischen
Drogen sind Ecstasy das in Pillenform
konsumiert wird Speed das geschnupft
wird und Crystal Meth das in
Kristallform in den Handel kommt und
geraucht oder ebenfalls geschnupft
wird es geht los janels und und sein
Team wollen das Drogenlabor nun stürmen
dass sie durch verdeckte Ermittlungen
gefunden
haben die Polizei rückt in Kolonne an im
schwarzen Transporter befindet sich das
schwer bewaffnete
Sondereinsatzkommando außerdem mit dabei
ein Bulldozer mit ihm wollen die
Polizisten die Tore der Halle aufreißen
sodass das Sondereinsatzkommando zügig
eindringen und mögliche Insassen
überraschen
kann
Tür Genet Tür ist geöffnet jetzt gehen
sie rein mit Gasmasken um sich gegen die
Chemikalien aus der drogenherstellung zu
schützen stürmen die Polizisten die
Halle beim ersten Tor werden die
Einsatzkräfte allerdings nicht
fündig alles kann geöffnet werden es ist
das Gebäude 52d bzw 2D meine ich s
öffnen ja öffne es wenn du meinst dass
da jemand
ist die Polizisten brechen ein zweites
und dann auch noch ein drittes Hallentor
[Musik]
auf in dem L wo wir sind in dem Lager wo
wir sind da sind Fässer mit Chemikalien
oder so da kommt nun das LFO und die
prüfen das was ist aber ich denke dass
es ein guter Fang
ist das LFO das sind bei der
niederländischen Polizei die Experten
für
drogenchemikalien sie müssen bei einem
Verdächtigen Pfund nach dem
Sondereinsatzkommando an den Tatort und
prüfen ob es Gefahren
gibt eine Untersuchung hat gemacht was
eine Untersuchung wurde gemacht was in
dem Labor ist ob da Stoffe sind die
giftig sind oder
so und wenn die sagen es geht dann
können wir
reingehen wir gehen kommt mal
mit nun dürfen auch die anderen
Polizisten den Tatort betreten und wir
mit
Ihnen die Kolleg von die Kollegen vom
LFO haben erzählt dass hier noch keine
Produktion war das ist ein Labor im
Aufbau also noch keine Produktion jetzt
können wir rein liegen die Sachen hier
liegen die
Sachen
das ist Rob de ist der Einsatzleiter des
LFO er hat gerade die Chemikalien
genauer unter die Lupe
genommen das ist ein Drogenlabor im
Aufbau wir sehen hier einen sehr großen
Kessel von um die 1000 l und wir sehen
die verschiedensten
absaugapparate das muss noch
zusammengebaut
werden und wenn du dir die Größe des
Kessels anguckst dann kann schon einige
h Liter Chemikalien auf einmal
kochen und wenn wir uns die Chemikalien
mal
angucken die sind hier in diesem Zelt in
den großen Fässern sind formamit
Ameisensäure und Phosphorsäure
drin ein
amphetaminlabor alles fast fertig große
metalltöpfe in denen die Chemikalien
gemischt und mit Hilfe von Gasbrennern
erhitzt werden und Tonnen Chemikalien
äuren mit denen die Drogendealer
geschätzt rund 1000 Kil Amphetamine im
Wert von ca ein Million Euro hätten
herstellen können in nur einer
Woche Jan beels und sein Kollege J
strohlenberg Sonderermittler für
drogenlabore bei der Limburger Polizei
haben schon viele solcher Tatorte
gesehen was auch besonders ist in diesen
Räumen sind die Chemikalien und das
Labor und daneben ist ein Raum wo die
Leute die hier arbeiten schlafen oder
eine Tasse Kaffee trinken können es ist
so dass wenn dieser Prozess läuft da
kann man d nicht mehr stoppen da muss
man dabei bleiben sonst wenn etwas
schief geht muss man angreifen können
und dann ist das schon ein Problem weil
die Leute die das machen
meistens nicht wissen was sie dann
machen müssen wenn es schief geht und
dann sieht man auch dass da Unfällen
geschehen dass man
sch verletzt wird das einiges explodiert
und so weiter und so weiter das haben
alles eigentlich schon mal gesehen die
Niederlande sind Europas Zentrum für die
Herstellung synthetischer und
pflanzlicher Drogen zufällig finden die
Polizisten in dieser Nacht noch eine
Cannabis Plantage gleich
nebenan größere Sorgen machen den
Ermittlern allerdings die synthetischen
Drogen
Chemikalien die wenigsten drogenköche
sind Chemiker und kennen die Gefahren
immer wieder kommt es zu Bränden und
Explosionen und Anwohner die meist keine
Ahnung haben was da in ihrer
Nachbarschaft passiert geraten in
Gefahr in diesem Prozess kommen ja
Dämpfer frei z.B da
könntemonmen
gefährlich tion könnte so hoch sein dass
man stirbt also die Leute die
reingegangen sind vom SE die haben
spezielle Schutzanzüge die tragen Masken
die die Stoffe
Filtern so dass die auch sicher arbeiten
können hier ist es noch ziemlich sauber
weil man ja noch im Aufbau ist meistens
ist es so dass es wenn man produziert
ist es schmutzig weil die wissen ja
nicht genau was die da machen überall
Chemikalien also man soll dann
vorsichtig sein wo man hintritt wo man
läuft es kann passieren dass die Schuhe
einfach weg schmelzen
brennen also die schon
gefährlich bei der Herstellung der
Drogen entstehen große Mengen giftiger
Abfälle in diesem Labor wären es laut
niederländischer Polizei für die ersten
1000 kg Amphetamine bis zu 30000 Kilo
gewesen wo landet all dieser
[Musik]
Giftmüll in Düsseldorf gibt es darauf
antworten das Landeskriminalamt
Nordrheinwestfalen der tatortforensiker
johannes zagermann hat 2019 die
chemischen Analysen im Fall Preußisch
Oldendorf
geleitet hier handelt es sich ebenfalls
um ein Labor zur amphetaminherstellung
auch als Speed oder Pep bekannt
in einer 3D Fotografie kann der
Forensiker von seinem Computer aus durch
den Tatort Streifen das ist quasi der
Blick aus der Halle nach draußen man
kann sich dann da drin umdrehen hat den
Blick in die Halle sieht hier schon jede
Menge gelagerte Kanister bzw diese IBCs
mit 1000 lit Fassungsvermögen teilweise
mit Abfällen weiter hinten die mit den
reinchemikalien die für die Synthese
verwendet wurden zwei Räume für die
edenen Schritte der
amphetaminsynthese der Aufenthaltsraum
für die
Köche ein aufwendiges Belüftungssystem
das die giftigen und stinkenden Dämpfe
filtert und nach draußen
transportiert Gerätschaften um 1000 l
amphetaminöl pro Woche herstellen zu
können gut abgeschirmt von der Außenwelt
außerdem 30 1000 l Kanister das Lager
für Chemikalien und Giftmüll bei einem
der Behälter machen die Ermittler eine
überraschende Entdeckung entscheidend
ist einer der Kanister der hier hinten
steht da können wir auch mal näher
ranfahren wo im Moment der Fotoaufnahme
hier noch so ein Sack drauf liegt auf
dem Auslass und das hat sich nachher
eben gezeigt ist dieser Punkt wo dieser
Tiefbrunnen gebohrt wurde und wo die
Abfälle entsprechend ins Erdreich
eingeleitet wurden ein Brunnen zur
Ableitung des giftmülls 12 m das ergeben
die Untersuchungen reicht das Loch in
die Erde die Ermittler sind alarmiert
der chemieabfall kann nicht nur den
Boden kontaminieren und Pflanzen Tiere
und Mikroorganismen abtöten auch
Menschen die mit den starken Säuren und
Basen in Berührung kommen können sich
die Haut veretzen und wenn sie
verunreinigtes Grundwasser trinken sogar
Schäden an inneren Organen
erleiden die Analysen der Polizei
ergeben das Labor war erst wenige Wochen
in Betrieb eine nieder ländische Bande
hatte es
eingerichtet wahrscheinlich hat ein
Kurzschluss den Brand in der
Destillationsanlage ausgelöst Glück im
Unglück so konnte das Labor bisher erst
wenige Drogen und damit wenig Müll
produzieren und ableiten ein
Umweltgutachten findet bei dieser Menge
keine akute Gefährdung für die
Anwohner wie viel letztendlich da schon
reingesickert ist
ließ sich nicht mehr feststellen wir
gehen aber davon aus dass es wenige 100
Liter erst waren zumindest aus diesem
Tank der da aktuell angeschlossen war
Besuch bei der Staatsanwaltschaft in
Maastricht Ermittler jan beukels ist
einem illegalen Chemikalienhandel auf
der Spur und will das weitere Vorgehen
mit dem Staatsanwalt Rob SMZ besprechen
treffen wie diese sind für Jan beukels
keine Seltenheit die niederländische
Drogenproduktion boomt Ecstasy und Speed
aus den Niederlanden schaffen es bis
nach Australien
80% der produzierten Drogen landen im
Export insgesamt machen die
Drogenkartelle laut einer europäischen
Studie jedes Jahr einen Umsatz von 19
Milliarden
Euro ein Geschäft mit zerstörerischen
Folgen der Abfall das sind ja auch
Chemikalien die belasten den Wald oder
laufen in den Fluss und das ist nicht
gut für die Natur aber auch nicht für
die
Leute wenn die Kinder da spielen oder so
diekmen mit das ist gefährlich ist das
gefährlich zusammen mit der amsterdammer
Kriminologin Channa mehlbaum fährt Jan
beukels zu einem illegalen Müllplatz für
Drogen mehlbaum untersucht das Phänomen
drogenabfälle landesweit von Jan beukels
erhofft sie sich Einblicke in die
Geschehnisse im Kreis Limburg einer
speziellen Region da sie im drei
ländereck Deutschland Belgien und den
Niederlanden
liegt
die Dinge hier in Limburg einer Region
im Grenzgebiet sind sehr verschieden im
Vergleich zu den norddlichen oder
östlichen Provinzen der
Niederlande die große Frage
transportieren die drogenköche ihren
Müll weit weg von den Laboren um das
Entdeckungsrisiko zu minimieren oder
entsorgen Sie den Müll nahe der Labore
was weniger Aufwand
bedeutet wenn du wissen willst wie weit
der drogenmüll transportiert wird musst
du wissen wo er herkommt meistens wissen
wir das jedoch nicht es gibt einfach zu
viele
deponen und dann gibt es die Theorie
dass sich Kriminelle auf das Einsammeln
und abtransportieren des Mülls
spezialisiert haben und an ganz eigenen
Plätzen
entsorgen Jan beukels zeigt Schan
mehlbaum einen dumingplatz direkt an der
deutschniederländischen Grenze ein
idyllischer ländlicher Ort tagsüber sind
hier wander und Radfahrer unterwegs
nachts ist es auf dem von Wäldern
umgebenen Feld dagegen ruhig ein
perfekter Ort um Müll los zu
werden das Gute hier ist dass der Müll
in Containern ist aber man sieht dass
die Kanister einfach hier hin geworfen
wurden und da ist das Risiko groß dass
Chemikalien
auslaufen und das ist natürlich
gefährlich für alle die mit ihnen in
Kontakt kommen bei zahlreichen Fällen
wird der Müll aber auch einfach direkt
auf die Wiesen oder ins Wasser gelehrt
und das kann natürlich heftige Folgen
für Pflanzen Tiere und für diejenigen
haben die zuerst damit in Kontakt
kommen rund 200 dumingplätze finden die
niederländischen Behörden pro Jahr
manchmal kippen die drogenköche den Müll
einfach in die öffentliche
Kanalisation da die Chemikalien ab einer
gewissen Konzentration die Funktion der
Klärwerke stören hat diese Methode
jedoch ein hohes
Entdeckungsrisiko wie Shan mehlbaum
untersucht hat entsorgen die Kartelle
70% ihres giftmülls in wenig besiedelten
Naturschutzgebieten oft klauen sie Autos
und LKWs laden Sie mit dem Müll voll
stellen sie irgendwo ab oder zünden sie
an oder sie bestechen Landwirte und
mischen den stinkenden Müll in die Gülle
so gelangt die Chemie auf die
Felder
250000 kg drogenmüll so viel landet
jährlich in den Fängen der
niederländischen Polizei schätzungen
zufolge ist das aber nur ein Drittel der
wirklichen
[Musik]
Abfallmenge wahrscheinlich werden die
Kartelle immer besser im verstecken und
Entsorgen des
Mülls über die Gefahren des drogenmülls
macht man sich beim Bundeskriminalamt in
Wiesbaden ebenfalls Gedanken der Fall
preußischoldendorf zeigt dass die
niederländische Drogenmafia auch in
Deutschland aktiv ist und der Müll
scheint an der Grenze nicht Halt zu
machen 2018 gab's einf da wurde einfach
ein LKW über die Grenze gefahren und
einem Polizisten ist aufgefallen dass da
eine braune Flüssigkeit rauslief und da
waren dann 10 Tonnen Produktionsabfälle
drin Michael Pütz ist ebenfalls
tatortforensiker und ausgebildeter
Chemiker bevor er uns erklärt was den
Müll aus dem Drogenlabor eigentlich so
toxisch macht zeigt er uns die
Drogensammlung des
BKA das ist eine Tasche mit EXC
Tabletten die Päckchen da drin enthalten
etwa 100.000 EXC Tabletten das ist eine
von zwei Taschen die damals
sichergestellt worden ist also insgesamt
waren es 200.000 Tabletten wenn Sie
einen Verkaufspreis von 5 € ansetzen das
ist zumindest so ein typischer Preis für
eine EXC Tablette für den Endkunden
haben Sie also bei zwei von diesen
Taschen einen Gegenwert von 1 Million
Euro 1 Million
für zwei Taschen das macht klar wie viel
Geld in der Drogenproduktion steckt und
weshalb drogenköche mit giftigen
Chemikalien hantieren obwohl sie wenig
Ahnung haben wie gefährlich das ist wie
gefährlich genau das demonstriert püz in
einem kleinen Versuch in jedem
amphitaminlabor wird man von diesen vier
Säuren mindestens zwei antreffen oft in
ganz großen Mengen das ist die
konzentrierte Phosphorsäure die
konzentrierte Ameisensäure die
konzentrierte schweel äure und die
konzentrierte Salzsäure und von jeder
dieser vier Säuren gehen spezifische
Gefahren aus die
eisensäure
z.B setzt wenn sie zu stark erhitzt wird
Kohlenmonoxid frei deswegen kommt es
immer wieder in den amphetaminlaboren zu
tödlichen Unfällen in Folge
Kohlenmonoxidvergiftung wir schauen uns
jetzt mal an wie die Wirkung von
konzentrierte Schwefelsäure auf
organische Materialien ist das
organische Material von dem spricht ist
simpler Haushaltszucker denn Zucker
besteht aus nichts anderem als
Kohlenhydraten und die sind ein
Grundbaustein des Lebens z.B der
menschlichen
Körperzellen was nun passiert die Säure
zersetzt oder besser verbrennt in kurzer
Zeit den
[Musik]
Zucker das würde auch bei lebenden
Systemen so funktionieren das heißt
natürlich kön kte ich mir meine
Hautoberfläche entsprechend verätzen
neben ätzenden Säuren enthält der Müll
noch weitere Stoffe und auch die sind
wahrscheinlich gefährlich die schlechte
Nachricht ist dass die diese ganzen
organischen Stoffe die als
nebenkomponenten entstehen bei der
amphetaminsynthese die sind eigentlich
alle gar nicht pharmakologisch
untersucht das heißt also man kann nicht
genau sagen welche toxische Wirkung von
denen
ausgt experten vermuten dass der
drogenmüll Krebs erregende Stoffe
enthält doch ob die zur Gefahr für
Mensch und Natur werden können ist noch
so gut wie gar nicht
erforscht eine Studie aus den
Niederlanden fand 2018 Reste des
chemischen Abfalls in Maispflanzen und
damit in der Nahrungskette ein
Einzelfall oder die Regel das weiß
bisher niemand denn es finden keine
flächendeckenden Screenings auf
drogenchemikalien
statt wie weit sich die Kartelle bereits
ausgebreitet
zeigt sich im ländlichen
Bereich Jan beukels trifft sich mit dem
Sprecher der Limburger Bauernschaft der
verdeckte Ermittler will wissen welche
Erfahrungen die Landwirte mit der Mafia
machen klar wird dass es die Banden auf
Lagerhallen und Scheunen abgesehen haben
um dort Drogen zu kochen und Abfälle zu
verstecken ich gebe mal ein konkretes
Beispiel da wurde ein Brief in den
Briefkasten geworfen in dem gedroht
wurde
wir wissen wo deine Kinder zur Schule
gehen mit anderen Worten die werden
erpresst und eingeschüchtert um
weiterzumachen oder ihr Betriebsgebäude
weiter zur Verfügung zu stellen obwohl
sie das eigentlich nicht mehr
wollen Bauer rompelberg selbst hatte
bisher Glück im Gegensatz zu Kollegen
und Freunden wurde er noch nicht von den
Kartellen
angesprochen doch er weiß gegen die
finanzst und bereite Drogenmafia ist nur
schwer
anzukommen wie aber kann das Problem der
drogenlabore dann unter Kontrolle
gebracht
werden eine Möglichkeit ist es das Übel
an der Wurzel zu packen und zwar indem
die ausgangschemikalien der
drogenherstellung frühzeitig aus dem
Verkehr gezogen
werden die Substanzen erreichen Europa
meist über den Seeweg aus China und z.
hier am Hamburger Hafen
an die Ermittler des Zolls haben einen
Tipp bekommen sie folgen einem LKW der
womöglich drogenchemikalien
transportiert so wir Container am
Container Terminal aufgenommen und den
werden wir jetzt zum rönken nach
Waltershof
bringen rönken das darf man in diesem
Fall buchstäblich verstehen tatsächlich
wird der Lkw in einer riesigen
röntkenanlage
durchleuchtet auf dem Computerbild zeigt
sich erst einmal nichts
Verdächtiges bin fertig kommst du so die
auswerung fertig K das gemeinsam
angucken aber ich habe keine
Unstimmigkeiten sit feststellen können
im Bild ja und der Container selbst ist
auch auch negativ der Container selber
ist auch negativ der da ist auch keine
Manipulation am Container selber ich
zeig dir hier noch mal ja
hier die röntkenbilder geben aber nur
einen begrenzten
Einblick türrum lang dann hier unten
Container die Ermittler entscheiden sich
deshalb den Container
[Musik]
aufzubrechen auchend mein Andruck ist
folgender dass die Ware sich im
Endeffekt nicht von dem unterscheide was
wir ja schon am röngebild vorab gesehen
haben wir können sehen auch jetzt im
Rahmen der manuellenkontrolle dass wir
eine unterschiedliche packweise der Ware
haben dass wir hier oben noch ein paar
Packstücke oben drauf haben was man auch
im Bild eindeutig gesehen hat hier gibt
es jetzt tatsächlich keinen
Verdachtsmoment der eine weitere
Kontrolle oder eine eine tiefergehende
Kontrolle rechtfertigen würde so dass
wir hier jetzt sagen können die Ware ist
aus unserer Sicht in
Ordnung bereits seit den 1990er Jahren
gibt es in Deutschland und den
Niederlanden eine Liste von Chemikalien
die als Ausgangsstoffe für die
Drogenproduktion gelten
der Zoll muss diese Stoffe
kontrollieren aber die drogenköche
ändern regelmäßig ihre
Rezepte außerdem verwenden viele Firmen
dieselben Chemikalien für ganz legale
Produkte die Arbeit des Zolls gleicht
deshalb der Suche nach der Nadel im
Heuhaufen die fander können nur einen
Bruchteil der Container wirklich
überprüfen
[Musik]
h in den Niederlanden versuchen die
Behörden Ines die Bevölkerung mit ins
Boot zu holen durch deren Mithilfe
sollen neue Labore schneller entdeckt
[Musik]
werden ein ehemaliger Polizist klärt die
Menschen darüber auf wie ein Drogenlabor
funktioniert und wie es
riecht
PMK ist der Grundstoff von MDMA und MDMA
ist der Wirkstoff
inasy wenn ich das Kinder Frage dann
wissen die das auch das PMK hat einen
sanften
aniesgeruch die Hoffnung wachsame
Bürgerinnen und Bürger denen auffällt
wenn es verdächtig in der Nachbarschaft
riecht melden dies der Polizei und die
kann dann die Ausbreitung der
[Musik]
drogenkartelleoppen unterwegs mit janels
er will uns einen besonderen Tatort
zeigen hier sind wir bei den zwei
Garagenboxen wo wir vor wenigen Monaten
waren wo das Labor war in der vier
befand sich das Labor und in der F waren
die
Chemikalien und das ist ja auch
gefährlich wenn die nebeneinander
stehenen ihren giftigen Müll haben die
Köche einfach in den angrenzenden Bach
geleitet die Folge der Bach wurde
verseucht und muss aufwendig wieder
gereinigt
werden hier war hier war das der
Schlauch kam um die Ecke und führte da
unten in das Wasser hier wohnen überall
Leute hier spielen Kinder hier sind
Tiere Haustiere die trinken vielleicht
von dem Wasser
vielle ja das ist sehr
besorgniserregend 6 Millionen Euro
kosten den niederländischen stat solche
Reinigungen pro Jahr die Risiken werden
dabei so gut wie nie genauer untersucht
auch in Deutschland ist das Problem
wenig im Fokus hier wird noch nicht
einmal zentral erfasst wie viele
illegale drogenmülldponien es pro Region
und jah
[Musik]
gibt